- If this shit ain't
makin' your dick hard,
I don't know what's wrong with you!
And everyone's like, what?
(heavy music)
(fire crackling)
Our guest is a fuckin' huge get.
Shout out to Black Lou, I
mean, the guy, super producer.
- Making a world of fans in
the campers community here
with The Bonfire, you
know, (laughs) there it is.
You know him, you love
him, I've been on the road,
they've been asking about
him, a lot of people
thank me for bringing this in their life.
On the phone, all the way
from, am I correct, Brazil?
- Brazil!
- [Sean] You got it.
- It's Sean Fury, everybody,
- That's right.
- Sean Fury, on The Bonfire,
how you doin' Sean Fury?
- [Male] Yeah!
- [Sean] Alright, how you guys doin'?
- We're doin' pretty good man,
usually there's a whole applause thing,
but our engineer decided to go away
and left a confused
young man on the board.
(chuckling)
- Yeah, we got our backup
quarterback on the board today.
- [Sean] That's alright,
I guess he's better
than the quarterbacks the Jets
have had the last five years.
- Oh, is there any Jets fans in here?
- [Sean] Not tryin' to diss!
- No, it's okay, no one
here is a fan of the Jets.
- [Sean] You know, I know the feeling.
You know, I'm a New York, New Jersey guy,
but the Steelers have always been my team.
- Got it, yeah.
- Elizabeth, New Jersey
your stompin' grounds?
- [Sean] Well, I was born and raised,
educated in New York, but, you know,
most New Jerseyans are former
New Yorkers who can't escape.
- Yeah, you just can't leave it.
- [Sean] So I got
smuggled out the country.
- Yeah.
- Now, we've been going
through your catalog
here on the show for a few weeks now.
- Yeah, I think we first
started with Bi-Racial?
The video our friend Des
- It was showed to us.
- showed us the video Bi-Racial,
and then we found a live performance,
and then we found our way
to your YouTube channel,
and we just went real deep.
We had a whole Sean Fury day, you know?
We got into it, and that's
why you're such a big get,
'cause our fans love
ya, and we got into it.
- [Sean] Thank you!
Thank you.
- I mean, there's some questions.
We definitely have some questions,
because as I said, we went in deep.
- Now I can't help but notice
- Go for it!
- the video for the song,
it's She Said No, No, No.
Is this have anything
to do with the reason
you're out of the country right now?
(chuckling)
- [Sean] (laughing) No, no...no.
They wouldn't let the
brothers get on the plane
if that was to happen,
especially if, you know.
You know the history of our country, so.
You know, black man, white
woman, he's not gonna make it.
You know, that's why I guess
Cos is going to jail, right?
- Well, yeah, I mean there's
many reasons (laughs).
So wait, you doled out
justice yourself though,
in the She Said No, No, No
video, at the end of it.
- [Sean] Actually,
whenever I do my videos,
I always try to keep it real.
Just like any time I write my
music, they're real stories.
They're, you know, this
is the people next door,
people you know, people
you're seeing on the bus,
the train, the people you
gave the middle finger to
while you're driving in the car.
You know, these are
real things that happen
and I always try to keep things real.
- So you do dole out
vigilante justice on rapists?
- [Sean] I would, if it was
a situation and I saw it,
and I'm right there,
I'm gonna do somethin'.
- Okay.
- [Sean] Sometimes you
have to be hesitant,
because I've seen in experience,
where a guy was smackin' up
his girlfriend in the street,
and I'm like four or five blocks away,
and I have on this big bomber
so it makes me look like
I'm hulking, you know?
And so, he's smackin' her up,
and as I'm getting closer,
I'm hearing the conversation, you know,
'cause you have to be careful,
'cause you might beat up the boyfriend
and she turns around,
starts cuttin' you up,
and you're the one going to
jail and everybody's going home
and you're the idiot, you know?
- I think that's a song, I
think you just wrote a new song,
right there, in that story.
- [Sean] Yep, so this
guy is gettin' smacked,
this woman is gettin' smacked
up and her friend is like,
"Yeah, girl! Don't take this from him!"
And he's smackin' up,
slammin' her face under there,
and there's police across the street.
Nobody's doing anything, and
then as I'm getting closer,
and then I hear him speak, and he says,
"And you cheated on me
for what, you slut?"
And I was like, uh-oh, wait a minute,
I can't get into this right now.
This is a little bit deep for me.
But the girlfriend, her girlfriend,
is still provoking this man, just like,
"You don't do this!"
And I'm looking, and I'm like,
at what point does this guy turn around
and realize that his girlfriend
is not doing anything,
but the one that's
talking is provoking him.
He should just leave, you know?
- Yeah.
- [Sean] And so, by the
time I got up there,
'cause then I start to
run, to get over there,
it's all broken up, they jump in the car,
and I'm sayin', this is real stuff!
You know, people don't write
about stuff like this anymore.
- Yep, you are Mark Vengeance.
Sean, if I could ask you
a question, Mr. Fury?
- [Sean] Mhm, mhm.
- Black Lou, who you spoke
with on the phone, I know,
Black Lou will tell you
his Stairway to Heaven
will always be the song Snow
you wrote on your album.
My favorite titles
maybe, on any album ever.
If you could bring that up, Christine.
- Ladies of Color album.
- Ladies of Color, yes.
- I mean, writing a song for every shade
of woman in the beautiful rainbow.
- Now, the balls.
- Of course.
- The balls, Mr. Fury,
that I believe you showed
in the writing in the titling of song
Indian Slash Arabic Girl, my
favorite part in the song being
when you say, when you
sing the word slash,
you say my Indian slash Arabic girl,
is one of the most fun
lyrics I've ever heard
in my entire life, I enjoyed that so.
(Sean laughs)
- [Sean] Well, actually,
I sat down years ago,
and I always try to be
different from everyone else.
And, when I realized that I
was dating all types of women,
(muffled laughter)
I was collecting notes in my head.
And I wanted to see, and share,
(stifled chuckling)
that they all have some of
the same needs and desires
but they just do things
just a little bit different.
It's not too much of a difference,
if they can't stand their boyfriend
or their husband, they let ya know.
- It's all the same,
- Ya know?
- Just different smells.
- Yeah, was it--
- [Sean] It's a universal thing.
I mean, I don't care, the
meekest woman that you can find,
if you leave that toilet seat up,
- Cut your nuts off!
- [Sean] she will have a problem, okay?
- Would you consider Ladies
of Color a concept album?
- [Sean] Yes.
Let's put it this way.
For the guys who have a
hard time speaking to women,
what they should do, for example,
a guy he says, "Oh! I'm in to these type
"but I don't know what to
say!", don't say anything.
- What if I meet a girl
in my neighborhood,
and I'm like, she's Indian or Arabic,
what song do I listen to
- Throw it on!
- to get a better clue?
- [Sean] Throw it on. Throw the record on.
- Black Lou said, "Ladies of Color
"is this generation's The Wall."
- Yeah. I call it Purple Rain.
(chuckling)
- [Sean] Ah.
- The songs are so entertaining,
I love that you're featured in the videos.
Can you, if you can, I don't
know if you can be honest here,
but these girls in the
videos, what percentage of 'em
do you say you broke off in real life?
- [Sean] Uh...
(muffled snort)
- You think he's counting on his hands?
(laughing)
- Yeah, I think he's doing a run-through.
- [Jay] (laughing) He is.
- He hung up?
- [Male] Yeah.
- He's gone?
- He's not on?
- [Male] He definitely hung up.
I'll call him back.
- That's hilarious.
- He goes, "Oh sorry man."
- [Bert] He had to have fucked
this one, there's no way.
- Yeah, I mean.
- [Bert] What if he's listening
to SiriusXM right now?
- In Brazil?
- [Bert] In Brazil.
(chuckling)
- He's just on a, he's just on--
- (Jokingly announces radio
show in foreign language)
- But do you think his
real last name's Fury?
- (snorting) Yeah, I believe
it comes from feral stain.
- Follow the money,
follow the paper trail,
let's find out this guy's real name.
It's also Mark Vengeance, is possible.
- Yeah, let's keep digging.
- (laughing) Mark Vengeance.
- Yeah, that's his alter ego.
Let's keep digging 'til we hit bedrock.
- Yeah, I wanna apologize to you, Bert.
We brought you into this,
I guess not as informed,
as I thought.
- Not as well-versed.
- Yeah, so Sean Fury was a guy
where we found out one video.
- Dude, that lady got
straight-up raped in that video.
- [Jay] It's the most graphic--
- It's the most graphic--
- It makes The Accused
look like a kid's movie.
- [Dan] It really does.
- Yeah.
- I would almost show that
at like, to scare teenagers,
you show that video and
go, "This what happens."
And they're like, "I don't like this."
- [Jay] Bert did you want--
- Yeah yeah yeah, I might
as well do a cocktail.
- [Dan] Yeah.
- I feel fuckin' like I'm, I feel like I'm
(clicks tongue loudly
three times) firing hot.
- [Dan] Yeah?
- Yeah.
- [Dan] Hell yeah.
Come on, I mean.
- What's he doing in Brazil?
- [Dan] (sighs) Well, maybe--
- [Jay] Running from the law.
- [Dan] That's why he
asked about this video.
'Cause it could be because of this video,
or it could be he's just
going to see some butts.
Is he on the phone?
Did he pick back up?
Or did he just hang up,
because he doesn't like Jay's
inappropriate questions for an artiste?
You don't say if they broke 'em off, Jay.
You ask how many of these women are his--
- [Producer] Okay, we're back on.
- Did he bed down?
- Did he bed? Hey, Sean, we
lost you now you're back.
We're just watching the video for Snow.
- [Sean] Sorry about that.
You know, it's like,
it's like my comeback.
So you know, I'm here,
boom, then I'm gone.
- But now you're back.
- [Sean] But let me
finish what I was saying,
I'm gonna address that.
No, the girls in Bi-Racial, no.
Snow, that's actually my
wife, and she was pregnant
with our twins when I did that.
So, I can't be breaking off anybody.
- I was gonna say, that
just killed the legend.
The legend of Sean Fury there, really.
You gotta keep that hidden
away from the world, man.
- Yeah, you can't, I
mean when you're a sexpot
you gotta hide it.
- You're a sex symbol.
- [Sean] Not really, cause when you hear
what I'm writing on the new
stuff when it comes out,
you know, and all these guys
cheatin' on their wives,
you know I got more stories to tell.
- Yeah.
- So, you know.
- Does it count as cheating
if you do it in Brazil?
- [Sean] Huh?
- Does it count as cheating
if you do it in Brazil?
- [Sean] Well...
Cheating is cheating, wherever you do it.
- But...
- But.
(laughing)
- [Sean] But if you're
keeping a scorecard,
then you have to look at
what your real focus is.
Do you really wanna go out
there and cheat on your spouse?
I mean, for years, for example,
you've heard people say,
"Oh, practice safe sex!" Well,
if you have to practice it,
you're not good at it.
Okay?
So, if you have to practice being safe,
you're not good at it!
So, be a professional.
- Just live dangerously,
- You know, protect yourself.
- is that what you're saying?
- [Sean] (laughing) You
know what I'm saying?
So.
- No.
- [Sean] Let me answer one more question,
'cause I try to address everything.
I always try to keep it
real and not real phony.
She Said No, No, No
whenever I do my videos,
I'm an equal opportunist.
I try to bring together everybody,
all the different types, and
what goes on in communities.
Originally, the cast was
supposed to be all Latino,
and I was supposed to come in
and still do my hero thing.
- Yeah.
- [Sean] The funny thing about it is
I always kept backups for my videos.
So I said, "If these people don't show up
"at this certain time, then
you got the job and let's go."
You know? So.
- You offered Latinos jobs
and they didn't take it?
- [Sean] Well, they do it!
They didn't show up, you know?
- Ay yi yi.
- It's Latinos, you know
how it is.
You know, so now, 'cause
I always tell them,
you know, in the video,
from the start, I said,
"You're gonna be famous."
'Cause I like to keep real people,
it's easy to get supermodels
who are starving to death,
you know,
(whispering)
and they look all hot, and you're like,
"Aw man! Yeah, but that's the
same guy, that's the same girl
"that was in so-and-so's video!"
No, people, I like to use real people,
doing real things, telling real stories.
- [Jay] No shit.
- [Sean] For example,
- I gotta, what I find interesting about
the video is quite graphic.
(snickering)
- [Sean] Uh-huh.
- And the song has such a,
like a bubbly tone to it.
- Yeah, almost like a beach tune,
but it's then scored on top of a video
that's very dramatic and very graphic.
- [Sean] Yeah, well here's--
- I mean, you give a real DeNiro level
of Goodfellas beating at the end of this.
- Yeah, that's a real stompin'.
- And I love the choice of
throwing the shirt to him.
- [Dan] Yeah, like, clean yourself up.
- Yeah.
- [Sean] Well, here's the thing
with that, with the video.
I mean, most people expect
a heavy song like that
to be a ballad.
- Yeah.
- [Sean] I mean, do you
really wanna be romanced
by a song, "Oh it sounds so, so sexual!"
But it's a horrible act.
- Yep.
- [Sean] But, when you hear it bouncing,
it's grabbing your
attention, and you're saying,
"Wait a minute, he's really
going into detail with this."
- Mhm.
- [Sean] And at that point, now you're in,
you're really getting the message,
'cause I'm not endorsing it.
I keep telling you this is
- No, not at all.
- [Sean] you know, what happens.
- That song's anti-rape?
- [Jay] Yeah.
- [Dan] Yeah.
- Exactly!
- Yeah, Sean shows up at the end, and.
- Oh yeah, okay, I'm sorry, yep!
Hey, (clears throat) did--
- [Sean] If you read some
of the stuff people say,
you would think, "Oh my god," what was it?
"He's probably fantasizing
about this, oh my god!
"He probably masturbates
to this, oh my god!"
(laughter)
No, I do fine without that.
I was doin' fine before I was married,
I'm doin' fine while
I'm married, you know?
The funny thing about
it, it's a serious topic
and most people don't realize the emails
that I have received.
- That's what I'm curious
about is the pushback.
Yeah, give me more.
- You probably get emails that go like,
"I'm walking to the store."
- Oh man, I can't believe,
yeah, probably stuff like,
"What is he doing in
that abandoned apartment?
"That apartment looks condemned."
- "Where is his furniture?"
- Yeah.
- [Sean] Yeah, yeah, yeah!
- "Who is this girl?
"Why does she look so,
actually frightened?"
- "Why is it gotta be a
black guy and a white girl?"
- "What bone deficiency
does this villain have?
"Why does he have bird chest?"
(giggling)
- [Sean] And you know,
and this is the reality,
that when this thing came out,
a lot of women wrote to me
and they said, "I never
thought about that!"
And I said, "Yeah!"
(laughing)
- Thought about what, being raped?
(muffled laughing)
- [Sean] No, they never thought about,
some of them wrote to me and said,
"Ah, I've been to trap houses
with some of my friends,
"and I never thought about that!
"I've been to frat houses,
I never thought about that!"
And I'm like, "Well, it's
usually a guy ya know!"
You know?
- Yeah.
- [Sean] And you have
these preconceived notions.
And then, when it came down to,
just happened to be a black
man, and a white woman...
- Well.
- [Sean] God did that one.
I was just the guy pullin' the trigger.
God did that (laughs) because I knew,
from the black community, I'm like,
"Oh my god! Man, why's it always
"got to be the brothers
doing this, going there?"
And from the white community, I got,
"See, I know! I knew
my neighbor next door,
"he wants to F me, I knew it!"
That's all I would admit was,
- Yeah.
- [Sean] You know, it's crazy.
- Especially if you
live in a predominantly
white neighborhood, they're
always lookin' at you like,
"Oh, look they're out
there watering their lawn,
"just like us, sir, everything is fine."
- "They have secrets, we all do!
"Rabble rabble rabble!"
- You know, I mean.
(laughing)
- [Sean] See, for me,
I've always been blessed
to experience a lot of people.
I grew, if you ever get ahold,
and I'm pretty sure
people who grew up with me
are gonna start sending pictures in.
And when I went to school
in my elementary school,
it looked like a UNICEF poster.
So, I've (laughs) I've heard
every kinda ethnic slur
and name coming across to everybody.
So, knowing what their hang-ups,
knowing how they felt, how
they dealt with it and--
- Well you know what's
funny, people have different
reactions to things, I think, because,
like Black Lou who works
here in the studio with us,
will tell us that, you know,
white kids growin' up used to
get time-out when they got in trouble.
But, black kids got time-out
from whoppin' that ass.
- Yeah.
Absolutely.
- Oh yeah, that's real!
- That is real.
- That's real.
- Yeah, you know what else is real,
is like our producer Christine,
and you know, it's not only just race,
it's also gender, because like,
our producer Christine'll
always tell us like, you know,
"Women be shoppin'! You can't
stop a woman from shoppin'!"
- [Sean] That's right.
(stifled laughter)
And it's, it's, and you know...
- (stifled chuckling) I can't do this.
- [Sean] It's just like
listenin' to the conversations
when people, when people are talking.
I've had many of experiences,
different parts of the planet,
and the interactions, and they say,
"Well, you speak with good diction."
I said, "I'm not that type
of guy, I'm not into dicks."
And they're like, "What! Did
you just say that to me?"
And you're like, "No."
Then I have to say, "I'll
translate it to you."
- Oh, yeah.
- [Sean] "I speak this way,
because ten minutes ago,
"I was just eating a white woman, so,
"I haven't quite digested her."
(chuckling)
And all the stereotypes will come out,
in the next five minutes
so you'll be fine.
- And then they tell their
friends, and they're like,
"Becky, Chad, come over here!"
- They go, "Hey, everybody, get around!
"Stop playing Frisbee, we gotta talk about
"this black guy that's
eating white women!"
- [Sean] Yep!
- This is my favorite
thing to worry about.
- [Sean] And that's how real it is.
But then again, a lot of my white friends
are more, some of them were more blacker
than black people
- They'll be like,
- [Sean] you know what I'm saying?
- They'll be like, "Yo, I know you think
"I smell like wet dog, right? Right?"
- [Sean] Na, they wouldn't
even say that, they would say
(snorting)
you would think, I would not say anything.
Because in the neighborhood
I grew up in, okay,
we were so tight and so close,
that anybody coming in from the outside,
you know, we could call each other names,
but nobody from the outside
could come in and do that.
They'd be like, "Oh,
somebody's cousin came in,
"and he starts calling somebody this."
And they say, "Hey man,
- Is anybody else having the
- [Sean] "keep that in check.
- best time of their lives
right now?
- [Sean] "Because that's my friend."
And, you know.
- Yeah.
- [Sean] You call some
Asian guy somethin',
and some Puerto Rican guy comes out
and starts whoppin' his ass.
- Yeah, you never know
where it's gonna catch it.
Sean, have you ever thought
about putting this all
together in one one-man show,
to hit the stage with it?
- Yes, I've actually thought
- [Bert] Because your voices are amazing.
- [Sean] about producing a movie.
So everybody can see the road I took.
'Cause it's not easy, the gatekeepers
don't let somebody in like me.
What they want, they want a Sean Fury,
and that's not my ego talkin'.
- But they want that bullshit.
- [Sean] Yeah, but they
want somebody who's a dummy.
- Yeah, they want you to play the game.
They want you to be their, you know.
- "Sign here, do this."
And before you know it,
all your money's gone.
- "Hey, gimme all your black magic,
I'm gonna turn it into green gold."
- [Sean] Yeah, they show you the door.
They're like, "This door,
some of your favorite people,
"are under these, doing
things you don't wanna see."
Well, and there and then
it's this door, the exit.
The get the hell outta here.
- Yeah, let's, I mean let's
really do the voice right.
They're like, "This door
has all the people inside
"doing bad stuff. This door is the exit."
- [Sean] Yeah.
I've always been the type
of guy to stand on my own,
do it myself, and I have the persistence,
and I teach my kids the same thing.
I say, "Listen, you wanna be successful,
"you only need two things.
"That's desire, and determination.
"You have those two things,
you're gonna go places.
"It'll take you longer,
tryin' to do it the right way,
"but, you'll get there and it'll last."
- Sean Fury, I 100%
agree with you on that.
- Hell yeah buddy.
We really appreciate you callin' in, man.
We're big fans, you are
next-level pop locker.
I really think you should be doing, like,
putting this together in stage.
Are you doing shows
while you're in Brazil?
You have anything you wanna plug?
- [Sean] Yeah, I'm actually doing some.
We're working on some other things because
in the Sean Fury story, I
actually recorded some stuff.
I sent LJ some music,
'cause a lot of people say,
"Oh, he's trying to do Michael Jackson."
Or, "He's trying to do that."
- No.
- [Sean] You know, I'm
a fan of everybody who's
- (laughing) No.
- touched the mic before me,
during me, and after me.
And it hasn't been released,
it's an homage to Michael,
'cause I actually wrote a couple of songs,
if you've seen the video Thriller,
I actually wrote that
to perform with Michael,
but then he died.
And then, I did a song--
- Wait, you said,
wait, wait, hold on, Sean, I'm sorry.
(laughter)
Did you just say you wrote Thriller?
- [Sean] No, not Thriller.
- No, not the Thriller.
- [Sean] My song was called A Thriller.
- So you could see how I
could misconceive (laughing)
you could see how I
could misperceive that.
- [Sean] Dan, do you know
what kinda controversy
you just caused from that statement?
I will get hate mail in the mail--
- I am so sorry.
- Did you write the song
Billy Jean King?
(laughter)
- Yeah (chuckles), I
wrote the song Beat It,
and Get Outta Here (laughs).
- [Jay] Beat It, seriously.
- Beat It with an explanation point.
- [Sean] I could hear them now.
I could hear them now,
they're like, "Wait a minute!"
Check this out, I've got stories
that you guys wouldn't even believe.
And the people that were there
will tell you that it's hilarious.
I'll tell you a quick, quick story.
It won't be a Bill Cosby-like lesson.
It'll be like, I almost had
a fight with Mike Tyson.
And this was fresh after
he broke up with Robin,
(laughter)
so you know he was a little,
a little different then.
- [Bert] Is this real?
- Not Mike Tyson now.
- Oh yeah, he was ready to go.
He was ready to rock.
- He was champ then, remember.
- Yeah.
He was droppin' everyone,
including Robin, hello.
- I with he would get in my way.
- [Sean] I met him at a Bobby Brown party.
And, this chick was screamin' at him,
at the top of her lungs,
'cause he was messin' around
with some other chicks in the VIP room.
- Okay, yeah.
- [Sean] And here I am.
Here I am, I see him earlier,
'cause I'm in the VIP room.
I used to get into these clubs,
people thought I was Ralph
Tresvant from New Edition.
I used to get into a lotta
clubs, I used to get guys
wanna beat me up thinkin'
I was Ralph Tresvant
from New Edition, if I show
you some earlier photos,
and you put him and
me, you'll say, "What!"
- I see it.
- Even when I met all of these
guys, they were sayin'
- I see it, oh yeah, Bert.
- the same thing.
- Oh yeah, I see it.
- [Sean] And, so.
- Yeah, Bert and I definitely see it.
- [Sean] And so, he, to
make a long story short,
I ran into him later on that night,
and this chick was makin'
this man's face contort
into five different
pieces, and he looked at me
like he wanted to put a hole
in my chest wit his fist.
And I told the man, you
know how it is in the VIP,
if you're in the VIP
room, you can't be soft,
because people start treatin'
you like you're soft,
and, you know,
- It's like prison rules
up there.
- You become somebody's bitch!
- Like the yard.
- [Sean] You know what goes on, alright.
- I set the rules, what
happens in VIP stays in VIP.
- [Sean] You damn right, but
this story is so hilarious,
if you see, you'd be like,
"No, it could not have happened that way."
And so, I'm standin' there,
and me bein' from New York,
you know New Yorkers,
they have an attitude,
they have a we don't
play that shit, you know?
- Straight-up.
- [Sean] He's from New York, I'm New York.
I don't play that shit, you
don't play that shit, so.
I turned around, and this man grabbed my,
I told him, because
everybody's watchin' me,
and they're watchin' him, they
gonna see how this reacts.
He probably gonna remember this.
And he says, and I said to
him, I said, "Calm down, baby!
(alcohol gurgles)
"If you lose 200 pounds,
I will bust your ass!"
(laughter)
I tried to walk off like
I was Bruce Lee, you know?
And everybody's lookin' at me like, wow,
he said that shit and he's still livin'?
- Yeah.
- [Sean] So I turned
my back, and my friends
stepped away from me when I said that.
I had friends, one of my
friends looked like Will Smith,
he was tall, and everybody
just said, "Excuse me."
And they moved outta the
way, to let this man decide
whether he wants to
put me in the hospital.
But I'm cool, I'm turnin' 'round like,
I'll whoop everybody's ass in here.
Now, quite naturally,
if he lost 200 pounds,
I would've outweighed
him, and in that day,
I wasn't fat then, alright?
I'm not like Martin, fat
Martin and skinny Martin.
So, I turned around, and this man came,
took up all of my forearm,
and he grabbed me,
and I'm looking, and he can't see my face,
and I said, "Aw, shit,
he's gonna hit me in here,
"and everybody's gonna
say I started the fight,
"I'll be on the news."
I turned back around, and I
put my baddest face on, like,
Huh!
Huhyulh, huh!
And he gave me a pound and he
was like, "Alright, we cool."
I was like, "Phew! This
coulda got ugly, man."
- (laughing) Mike Tyson goes,
"Your mouth works out a bit."
(chuckling)
- Yeah, he goes, "You know
what? I just did it in my head.
"You're right."
- You're right.
- He goes, "Huh, hah, huh?"
- Yeah.
- "Escue me, are you
saying my current weight,
"or the heaviest I've ever been?"
- Those are the noises that shut him off.
- [Sean] I'm tellin' you.
(bleeping decrescendo)
(cackling)
- [Sean] All kinds, man
like I said, story after
(robotic whoosh)
story after story.
- Well Sean, thank you
very much for callin' in,
we appreciate it.
- Hey Sean, can I
plant one seed?
Your next music video, I know two guys
who would love to be the actors in it.
- This is Bert Kreischer, Secret Time's,
new special's out on Netflix
right now, comedy special.
- So he ain't bullshittin'.
- Um, yeah.
- [Sean] Well, you guys, hey.
You guys set it up, hey,
I'll put up, you know,
I'd love to do a comedy
show and some movies
and everything like that.
You guys are connected there, you know?
I mean, you guys could,
it's Comedy Central, hey.
- I'll be dead serious, I'll pay for,
we'll pick the song, and
we want you to direct it
like you normally do, your artistic view,
and we'll be the actors,
we've got a big cast here.
- Perfect, we got seven
cast members already.
- [Sean] Hey, we can put
that together, you know,
I'm very grateful, this comes
from the bottom of my heart,
that you guys, you know, are pushing me.
'Cause, you know, sometimes
I still get people emailin'
and all kinds of stuff,
- Oh, just like, "Sean Fury,
- I get hate and like...
- "what's up with your fuckin'
"music, it's."
- It's crazy, it's like--
- You can't, haters are gonna
hate, Sean, you know that.
- You know what you should tell 'em?
Lose 200 pounds, I'll fuck you up.
- [Dan] Boom!
- Yeah.
That should be the title of a song,
(lauging)
Lose 200 Pounds I'll Fuck You Up.
- [Sean] That's right, there it is.
- Sean, you have a great time in Brazil.
Be careful, some of the
prettiest chicks there are dudes.
But that really could be
a whole new concept album,
my friend.
- Hell yeah.
- Sean Fury, joining us
on The Bonfire everybody.
Thank you so much, Sean.
- Thanks, guys.
- Go to Sean Fury dot com,
check out all of his stuff.
We are big fans, we know
here, on The Bonfire.
- Well let's call, but let's--
- Let's take a break?
- Yeah, let's take a break.
We'll come back, yeah.
- Come back, and
we'll talk with Bert Kreischer.
And I got a feeling this
next hour's gonna fly.
- Yeah, I gotta pee.
- Alright.
- I gotta pee, because it's
- Yeah.
- probably gonna go by pretty quick.
Let's go.
- Yeah. Alright.
You know we'll be back
everybody, it's The Bonfire.
(fire crackling)
- Bam, endless hits.
- (singing) My girl.
- (singing) My girl!
- Oh, by the way, that wasn't
The Temptations My Girl,
his song is called My Girl is For Me.
He ain't sayin' he wrote
The Temptations My Girl.
- Brilliant.
Have you ever heard his
song Welcome to the Jungle?
(laughter)
- Oh, dude, yeah, I mean, he
wrote one of my favorite songs
Comfortably Numb, goddamnit.
- Not that one, though.
- Yeah, man, it like--
- Not that Comfortably Numb.
- Yeah.
He misspelled numb.
- I can only say, probably
the best interview
we've ever done.
I mean, gripping, riveting.
- Never had more fun
on the radio.
- When he said, "I wrote
Thriller," I fucking looked at you.
(laughter)
- Yeah, and that's when I was like,
"Are you saying you wrote Thriller?"
And he's like, "Fuck".
And he's like, "No."
Like I was the asshole.
I go, "You just said you wrote Thriller."
He goes, "Aw, well you just,"
by the way, I don't know--
- (laughing) No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
All need to better by, I
had a lot of girls watching
that video and go, "I
never thought about that!"
(laughing)
- Yeah, he goes, I could be--
- That I could be
brutally raped (cackling).
- Yeah, in a frat house, and at first
I thought he said a trap house.
- [Jay] He did, he did.
- I go,
you're in a, he did?
- He did say it, he did
he said trap and then frat.
- You're in a crack house,
and you didn't think, you don't
think they're selling drugs
and there might be some
rape going on occasionally?
- People ain't willing to
talk about the real shit.
- Dude.
- Oh, fuck.
- Can I just tell you right now,
I was blown away by that interview.
At multiple points in the interview was I,
was I a little like, "Oh
shit, this really got,
"this guy is who he really is."
- Blown away by what just
happened in this room.
- But then I realized, the
delusion comes because,
I don't think he knows
how large our audience is.
I love the size of our
audience, but he was like,
"Guys gettin' the blogs after me."
I'm like, "No, that's not gonna happen."
- Dude, it's got nothing to
do with the value of our show.
- Not the value of our audience, the size.
- We've had a bunch of blogs written
about things on the show,
good or bad, you know?
- Yeah.
- But, I don't know if
they're gonna write one
about Sean Fury, a blog about this?
- Well that's what he said, he's like,
"Oh, you guys are gonna
get the press all over me."
- [Jay] Oh man, that's all I need.
- Now all I need.
- That's all I need again.
- I'm in here in Brazil, tryin'
to get back with my family.
By the way, every time you
asked him a funny question,
there was a five minute wait to rebuttal.
(chuckling)
And there was always just a sidestep.
- He'd always go, "Yeah,
you know it." You know?
- Yeah, that was, great job LJ.
- [LJ] (laughing) Oh, no.
- No, that was good.
- Yeah you're no longer
Black Lou.
- [Jay] LJ!
- LJ!
- LJ, fuck Larry Johnson,
you're no longer Black Lou.
- Can I simply say one thing?
- Hell yeah.
- I don't think he's in Brazil.
- [Dan] You think he's just
in Patterson, New Jersey?`
- Yeah.
- Just takin' a call in the back?
- [Jay] Well, say what?
- And by the way, that might
be the most brilliant thing
I'll start doing when I do call-ins.
- [Dan] Call in from an international?
- I'm in Hong Kong.
- [Dan] International Bert Kreischer?
- Why wouldn't you be?
- Dude that's so great.
- I'll tell you, Lou had to call him
on one of those like, zero, zero, zero,
something one, four,
eight, five, six, one.
- [Bert] I'm gonna start
telling people I'm in Brazil.
- Do it. I like it. And you know what?
Besides us, and the
listeners that are listening
right now, I won't blow it for ya.
I'll go, "Did you talk to Bert?
Where in the world is he?"
- Oh, hey guys, it's Bert, I'm in Paris.
It's like a Scott Peterson thing.
- Yeah, yeah.
- (laughing) Do you remember
when Scott Peterson did that?
- Yeah, he's like, I'm in Thailand.
I'm in Bangkok right now for the weekend.
- I'm in a hot air
balloon over Deutschland.
- I'm at the Reykjavk funny bone.
- Oh my god.
- For Thursday, Friday and Saturday.
- How fucking funny, oh my god.
I'm gonna set up a press tour, on phone,
and just get sound effects.
- Yeah. Just like stream balloons.
- I'm in a hot air balloon
(loud whirly gurgle).
(laughing)
- They go, "Bert you're living
a very," it's the interviews
you could tell they don't
give a shit about you.
Where they're like, "What are
you up to, Bert Kreischer?"
- In the background you hear
(singing) "come with me, and"
you go, "'Scuse me for a
second, guys, 'Shut up, Wonka!'"
(laughing)
- I'm on the phone.
- Sorry.
What were you saying, scooter in the buzz?
Mornings on
- I'm on the phone with,
- Akron, Ohio's number one rock station.
- with the bone.
- (laughing) Up next,
we got Bert Kreischer.
Bert Kresicher, how you doing?
"First rule of fight club!"
"I'm sorry, I'm at my
fight club." (laughing)
- Yeah, yeah.
- Bert Kreischer callin'
in (screams in Russian).
He's in Siberia, I forgot
he's doing a weekend there.
- (laughing) I like how he goes,
"First rule of fight club!"
He goes, "Oh, sorry, I
can't talk about Fight Club.
(laughing) "Wait, no I can't, nothin'."
- Oh, you know what?
- I'm nowhere.
- He just told me again, he does it
like he's hearing rule two,
"Yeah, they just said it again.
"I can't talk about it."
- I heard Zach Galifianakis
do a call-in on time,
and he had a chainsaw with him
- That is awesome.
- and he called in, and they're like,
"We got Zach on the phone,
Zach are you there?"
He goes, "Yeah, hold on (vrooming)."
And you just hear the chainsaw
(buzzing) and he's like,
"Stop it! Sorry, we're building
a tree house." (laughs)
- Yeah, that's great.
I think you should go
international full-on lock.
- Why wouldn't you have
more fun with your call-ins?
- I mean, Sean Fury's just
straight-up international.
- He was wonderful.
- Yeah.
- [Bert] What do you
think production costs
on one of his videos, five grand?
- $200.
- What? (laughs)
- Are you talking about for catering?
If you're talking about
catering for everyone
that was involved, $135.
- I'll tell you right now, alright,
as God as my witness, I would pay,
I'll pay five thousand dollars,
if I can put it on my YouTube channel?
- [Dan] Yeah.
- To produce a Sean Fury
video with all of us in it.
(excited sigh)
Sean doin' the singing to the camera,
and all of us are acting
out the scene behind him.
- [Dan] Can we write?
- I'll pay five thousand dollars.
- Can we write the story, of the video?
- [Bert] Nu-uh, I want Sean to do it.
- You're right, I'm so sorry.
- Yeah, I want Sean to do it.
- Can I just apologize?
- What do you think?
This is his vision, man.
- I'm sorry, I'm sorry.
- [Bert] Yeah.
(heavy guitar chords)
(fire crackling)
(loud boom)
(beeping)